all right platinum
howdy platinum where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
well born at hollywood presbyterian
born and raised out in los feliz um
hollywood california i live in
california what is your family like
my family like
well
i come from a bloodline of um
extremely
extremely extremely beautiful people um
my dad um on my bloodline side was a
biker for filthy few out of san
bernadino
and um
he knocked out my mom who was beautiful
um
i believe she bred horses
and um
anyways
my mom was young and my dad was
busy being a badass musician and biker
so um
they
put me up for adoption after um
after all said and done so i was raised
by a
the most like beautiful beautiful man
and woman you've ever met in your life
um
[Music]
um
my mom's a nurse spina bifida nurse
practitioner
and my dad is a rocket scientist working
with boeing
and his own companies and he's retired
now
worrying about me
and um
has every right to be you know
anyways they're the most beautiful
people in this side of georgia and
probably that side too
they're a beautiful jewish family out of
las feliz like i was saying and um
i've got one brother
well one brother that was also adopted
into their family
and he's
[ __ ] he's amazing too he's in france now
with his wife
and um
and then i've got i've got two other
bailon well two actually blood siblings
um
i have my older sister
oh god i could go on crying about her
for days
she's um
she's the moon in my night sky
she's um
she's she's those stars that
don't stop shining
no matter how smoggy it gets over l.a
thanks
and then i got my crazy
crazy brother richard
who um
[ __ ]
he's and he takes after my paw my dad
they're all my dad's kids
my real father and they all we all have
different moms
and um
um
we're bad as [ __ ] you know pardon my
french with all due respect um
or something else or something else
yeah were your teenage years like
oh my gosh i was in and out of
in and out of all the i was kicked out
at lausd when i was um about 13 in
seventh grade for some nudie pictures
that my girlfriend took of myself while
i was at my parents were at the street
fair i am my girlfriend and i were being
normal teens and uh we took some
polaroids that
i wanted to take to school for my
boyfriend yeah well i got him to school
all right and the teacher found him so i
uh
had cps show up at my parents house that
evening and
as i ran to the bathroom and took a
bunch of tylenol and trying to uh figure
out oh my god my parents are seeing
these pictures do i want to do i want to
be another day in this household um
i um
i got dismissed from all the public
school systems out here out there out
here in los angeles so i went to private
schools continuation schools mainly all
throughout the valley kelp and southern
california pretty much i was bused on
the little blue like little little
school bus every which way from sunday
everywhere everywhere
and uh kicked out of quite a few of
those for smoking pot behind the shed
that type of thing
yeah
yeah do you have kids
do i have kids um
i've got
one beautiful beautiful daughter
just as much as i have her she has me
you know in our in our in our lives we
um
we go through
we go through a lot and i believe it all
happens for its own reason
i sure am a really really really firm
believer in that
so
when i got pregnant with her
um
there was no offense or button whether
or not i was going to keep her
you know to have her
um
which i did i gave birth to a beautiful
um
about seven pound baby
this little
fat healthy
beautiful girl with a beautiful smile
and i was malnourished
during the time of birth and my face was
cracked open pretty bad to where um i
was pushing her out and there was blood
pushing from my face
so
i uh
i made it up to northern california um
and the day i went into labor i jumped
in a ride share and went up to vallejo
went to vallejo kaiser permanente where
my girlfriend
delivered my beautiful beautiful
daughter evangeline
and um
although she was taken at birth she was
never taken
you know
um
you never leave your kids you know you
were using drugs at the time
during the pregnancy
at the beginning half of it yeah i was
um that's why they took her
no do you have no drugs in your system
on my skin
my husband will tell you otherwise he'll
say oh she got the daughter taken
because she had dope in her system no
kid doesn't have drugs in her system at
all
um the day the day i went into labor um
after i after i popped her out i and
freaking
i took ahead of dope and um i told him
about it so
i gave them this test too which was
really probably stupid but um i was just
being honest i was being way too honest
for my own good
but no she had no um
drugs in her system and um
you know she'd be able to tell you that
if um
when she sees this you know she'll have
the paperwork
i think i've signed it to where she
could
figure out everything or you know be
given all the
a's and c's a to z about me when she
turns 18. so no no drugs in her system
so you have one child
uh no no no i did not just have one
child i had two um
i have an eight-month-old baby boy in
heaven um his name is caleb
allen scott janice
and um
that was nine nine and a half year one
october 13 2013 that i
that i am
i buried that baby boy um
along with his father
um
excuse me
uh humble county northern california
what to say about it is um
it'll give you life
just as easy as it'll take life
and
um i know that rodeo well you know um
they can't tell me how my son
died they say it's an inconclusive death
certificate
and i have to um
keep trucking with that one every day
you know cuddled with him in the morgue
for the first
two days um
after he passed four hours the first day
three hours the next
and um
i went
and that's how i started doing drugs i
mean
you know i went to um
i went to the dealer's house right then
there and said make me numb um there was
a three-day manhunt for my husband
because he dropped my son off at the
hospital then on arrival
and
they looked for him in the hills of
mendocino county for three days manhunt
atvs helicopters um
search dogs you name it
and um
he was a man a man of mendocino and um
well you you know the hills over there
and uh he knew them better than he knew
his own self so he was able to um divert
the law and um
he had he hid up there is what we can is
what we put together because his body
was found a quarter mile from our 168
acre
family
farm
ranch he was found a quarter mile from
our property
um two bullet holes to the head they
said he had to shoot himself twice the
22 rifle
which makes no damn sense at all
you know um
it's controversy as to what happened or
i don't know if it's controversy it's
the word the name for the word for it
because i'm not really quite sure what
that means
but um give or take uh
they can't tell me how my son died and
it's my husband's body was
unrecognizable when they found it his
dad identified the body
my husband had tattoos head to toe he
was uh
he had a smile you couldn't you couldn't
even
you couldn't even
couldn't even fake or drop or buy from
mcarthur park you know
anyways um
i miss them every day
and um
you know sometimes i'm even crazy enough
to think hey
you know maybe it's a hoax
maybe um
maybe they're really not dead after all
maybe they just went into hiding or
something stupid but we all have
conspiracies and um
you know i just i'm just grateful i was
able to have them in my life
you know for
the amount of time i did
and where's your life gone since then
um
where hasn't it gone
um
it uh
i was in the slammer out in arizona the
day of my my son's funeral i was um
i was asked to
check in with probation
um not control probation in arizona
for um
i had had a i was on probation for
aggravated assault misconduct with
firearms
um out of arizona like i was saying i
was renting to buy private airstrip in
lake montezuma arizona i had a house out
in rimrock um
on a private airstrip i was renting to
buy and um i was growing a bunch of weed
and i had about 448 plants in the
airplane hangar up there
and um
i had a bunch of customers in the house
like a bunch of weed customers you know
partying and my brother shows up from
sfv with a harley and [ __ ]
all methamphetamine militia out and uh
comes and knocks on the door and um i'm
like hey bro it's not the time right now
you know
you know here's a few bills can you go
to the casino you know figure some
things out i just come back in a day or
two
and it's been a long time coming with
him and i i've i've loved him all my
life he's been he's when i say my
brother
really he's uh he's my first he was my
first real lover um we're not related we
just grew up side by side not like side
by side in the same household but he's
from sfe and i'm from hollywood and i
claim sfv so
you know mainly because of him you know
out there at tampa and wells was mom and
dad's house on his side
and when he showed up
and i told him to bounce he leaned
against the doorway like you know he
owned the spot
and
i on the spot like i was married at the
time and my husband was off at war and i
was supporting
that household's rent
another household to rent right in
durango colorado for my for my lady and
i was paying my brother's wages out in
colorado
as well grant injection so i'm like wait
a minute wait a minute and um i didn't i
didn't even think a second or wait any
[ __ ] damn minute i um i headbutted
him and i grabbed his pistol
from his holster like he [ __ ] taught
me to do
he taught me how to fight how to
do multiple other things anyways um
private security right so i grabbed his
pistol and i pissed whipped him with it
because um and at that point you know i
had already headbutted him now pistol
whipped him i thought well [ __ ] i'm i'm
in some trouble here he's a big boy and
i mean big boy this man is um
he's a he's a walking talking
you know
disaster child just like myself anyhow
he um
he stunnedly stepped back and i
grabbed his gun lock and
i guess um
i um
inappropriately kind of just got
uh out of control and i hit him like 32
times or something with it
and so he went and
i let the fire station know that you
know
he had gotten
beat up pretty bad by his baby sister
and she's toting guns and [ __ ]
growing weed up on the airstrip
so atf dea
and um all of arizona [ __ ]
law show up at my spot and um
i'm like driving in my s in my african i
was renting a car and i had my beautiful
big white wolf with me white thorn and
we're driving and we're watching we're
watching the cops on the house right and
i'm like [ __ ]
but this is not this is not going to go
away i mean they're they're [ __ ] guns
drawn [ __ ] all around all around the
house all on the airstrip and
i called my lawyer out here in
california
the best damn lawyer
and the best and one of my best friends
um
till this day she uh i said gail i'm
like like damn it they they i [ __ ] up
this time i said well i [ __ ] up again
let's put it that way and she goes
baby girl you got an apb out at the
border you know you might as well turn
yourself in
and so i drove up
and i'm like hey copper is my brother
okay
and it took him a minute i mean they
were all you know their backs are to me
and i'm driving up in my in my vehicle
anyways probably seeing a little bit too
much but i drove up and i'm like you
know i approached him i'm like hey is my
brother okay and it took them like 30
seconds to tell me to get down on the
floor or they didn't realize it was me
or some [ __ ] like get down and get down
after [ __ ] a good 30 seconds to be
standing there like
you know
yeah
yeah
so
um arizona police department you know
second yeah by county um so i was on
probation for all that and i um i missed
probation check in the day of
my son's funeral i had an interstate
compact thing going on and um
i ended up doing four and a half years
arizona state pen um a few months after
i buried my son and my husband
so i you know
i had a boring future of justice nobel
warren out for my arrest and i turned
myself in
to do the time get behind me i probably
would have been
you know [ __ ] off my life to a
certain extent to where i would have not
been alive today if i didn't do that
present time so i'm more than okay with
it my poor parents but yeah and since
prison you've done what
oh gosh golly um
well actually right after prison i am
and see i stayed um
i stayed at my parents house after i was
done with the whole you know probation
get down out there in arizona or maybe i
interstated again anderson compacted
again i'm not sure
um
anyways i ended up there at my parents
house and
i had called a girlfriend of mine and
said hey listen i'm back in town and i
really um i really want to go out you
know i'm i'm broken up with so-and-so
now um
you know you have anyone you can
you can suggest and she's like i sure do
um
i i'm gonna send my my uncle over there
he'll be there shortly and um
shortly really meant 15 minutes i got a
phone call um
you know
robert's out front
the minute i saw that man
the minute i saw him
i went god jesus boy
i said i know that smile from somewhere
i said i know that smile from somewhere
and a year and a half later i saw it on
my daughter
during that time that um
i was pregnant with her and um
i was
getting to spend
the years of
our lives in this lifetime at least
with him
this time around um
the pregnancy was hard
it was hard we stayed at
his mom's house there in glendale his
mom had already passed
and um
i loved robert with every single every
single inch of my being in soul and i
still do
um his brother had uh
had tried to coerce me about a month and
a half after being pregnant with his
daughter
and um
i turned him down you know i'm in love
with your brother what is this and uh
so
yeah he told his brother
um when he got home from work that he
had caught me with a um
with a black man in his bedroom while he
was at work
um you know being being there like um
you know
sexually active and um
problem was i did have a friend of mine
over
christian who was giving me a lot of
advice um he's a lawyer's assistant he
was rest in peace
um
and so
i was i was screwed you know i was
screwed i was like yeah i had somebody
over but i wasn't i wasn't [ __ ] him
you know and uh
well of course um
you know he believed his um
good old pal over me so
so what are you doing on skid row now oh
what am i doing on skid row wow what
brings you here
pardon what brings you here what brings
me here
probably a better question than what
what is it that i do down here um what
brings me here is um the drugs i um
i
i kind of lost it after i gave up um
my daughter for adoption i am i came
back down here to southern california
because i was up there in northern
california for a while visiting her
and trying to hold my bearings up there
being um
you know being homeless dealing with cps
and
i mean not homeless exactly my parents
put me up in a hotel for a while and
then when things started getting a
little bit
you know
effectively like i was i was supposed to
come down to los angeles and watch
bobby's mom's house out there in
glendale while he went to prison
he was going in for about three years we
already knew it
we had been fighting in court for quite
a while and so
um we
we decided okay i would come down
from solano county
and you know take care of
take care of things down here in los
angeles and um
wow
i i could say i did but i i am
i didn't because i am i stayed at the
house for the first week until i was
asked to leave by the lapd
um i guess bobby had sold the property
and
so i um i became homeless for the first
time in my life
and um
skid row is where i ended up
um
i met some of the most
trifling trifling people down here
but i met some of the most beautiful
beautiful people that i've ever met in
my life
i've met some really beautiful ones in
europe you know especially switzerland
but um
i've got my drummer here
my two guitarists um patty and ziggy
and um
you know i uh
i wouldn't trade them in to uh
you know get clothes on and if i was
naked on a rainy day i wouldn't trade
them in for anything i am i love them
with all my i live i love them with all
my heart and soul
my name my band is nbw for nobel
warrants right and uh because i never
had bail
um i thought it was crafty i came up
with it while i was
you know um
spitting some tracks with my my girl up
there in linwood county
one year um victoria and we uh we put
together this album and we we certified
it we called ourselves nbw and uh
so i brought that out here the streets i
mean i'm i'm really the only you know
functioning member in my band not really
functioning at all but you know i
haven't seen vicky for the past few
years and uh
my drummer like i said i have which i do
and my two guitarists um they're just
we're not we're not all
we're not whole yet so i mean they are
in my band actually okay so maybe i'm
not the only one i don't know we will
figure it out but um
yeah i hope i answered your question i
kind of was sidetracked but no i think i
did yeah yeah the drug you're using now
is is why the drug i'm using now
is the double um
it's i believe it's chemical warfare you
know i believe that um as it may be a
conspiracy theory but i believe fentanyl
was brought here to um
to kill off the american dream um
heroin i think was i'm cracking heroin
produce we're producing the community
and um didn't do a good enough job you
know they give us something we kill
ourselves with
i mean that's [ __ ] brilliant
chemical warfare if you ask me
and how do you support yourself now
okay supporting myself now um
[Music]
well
i i'm a dominatrix certified out of
oakland so
i've been trying to get a get in touch
with the dungeon here in downtown l.a
but i'm
i run i run my own gig um
right here i'm just good well actually
we have like you know kind of like an
after hours um
situation and uh
i uh i'm not having any i got no trouble
with it like
you know
there's a market for
from combinations yeah there's a marvel
dominating
dominatrix market 101.
yeah there's a lot of a lot of people
that are into
all kinds of stuff right there yeah
especially down here yeah
you still have friends
do i still have friends
um
you know i miss my friends so when you
say do i still have friends
um
i miss i miss my brother jordan when i
did the prison term before
i haven't talked to my girlfriend joelle
who delivered my girl
in
too long
and i have
friends now and
i have them in my heart
you know and i've got
a lot of acquaintances [ __ ] everyone
knows the name platinum you know but uh
someone i could turn to
um
sunny
i have sunny
yeah i have sunny cool and he's my he's
my friend all right
he's my manager
and i'm
one of the most um
he completes the complete circle anyways
uh
sunny cool is cool man you know it ain't
cool
it ain't cool no more sunny
it ain't cool
it's said i got sonny cool i have
friends i have a friend yeah what are
you afraid of what am i afraid of
at this point in your life oh daddy if
here's an insult to god
i don't have any fear that's the problem
um that's probably a really big problem
with me um
i uh i
just got stabbed up on skid row um about
a month ago
your scars are pretty impressive scars
are pretty impressive
show me your arm yeah i am
my nails aren't done right now i'm a
little bit upset about that i'm actually
very upset i'm on my way so don't
don't judge
uh i did i did a surgery or two um to uh
to get my hand better but
i haven't even shown my parents yet
so um was that over
someone had stolen some you have another
one on your leg yeah i do
someone had a
someone had stolen some money from me
and uh
the money belonged to somebody else
and so um
i uh i wasn't able to put the money
together in time
um or at least that's what i believe it
was over you know um
oh yeah
i told law enforcement that uh
there is uh
some something in a clown suit uh you
know [ __ ]
you know
i am
i don't know the guy's name or anything
like that so it's not
anyways you know
give any regrets in your life
i have no regrets life is um
life is life is definitely what we make
of it and i believe it's pre-planned so
if i run with regrets or if i run with
fear i'm
spitting on god you know
[Music]
god is beautiful god is
in my beliefs you know i mean he's um
he's pre it's this is all pre-planned i
mean i believe that we have
we have um
we have choice we're like we know we
have choices um
we can
we can
strive for
strive for better strive for
okay like with numerology um you
graduate like you know one through nine
it's your in and that's your life like
that's your life path and i believe that
if um
next lifetime if i do maybe
something different maybe my son won't
pass away that you know in the next
lifetime anyways it sounds kind of
cougar for cocoa puffs so i'll leave it
alone but um mainly
no no no fear no regrets yeah
okay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life holy [ __ ] um well
you gotta get it while you can
you know
you gotta get it while you can
that's the most important lesson i've
learned
i haven't learned all the lessons in
life yet i'm still open for a suggestion
and
knowledge is power so you know
all right all right then thank you so
much for sharing your story
oh yeah you're welcome everyone
you're welcome
stay out of trouble
i stay out of trouble and trouble needs
to stay out of me you know
the trouble needs to stay out of me yeah
all right thank you very much
you